- Headed to Portland, early morning.
Red-Eye back, grinding on this Monday.
Let's do it.
(Southern rock music)
♫ Am I too dangerous
♫ For you dear
♫ Scared of a little smoke
♫ And the music's too loud for your ears
♫ You've been wasting
- We're running early.
- It's so impressive.
It's like, literally the first time
I ever heard such a thing.
Already been covered based on
what you guys know about me,
based on what you know about them?
Where do you think you want me to go?
- We've been think-
- [Assistant] And I think
the one topic traveled-
- Offense?
- [Assistant] Yeah.
- Yeah, there's also
already questions asked.
♫ Then you want to see
♫ That the glorious
(laughter)
- Is it one of those thin ones?
I see yeah, this much
time for the whole thing.
- [Assistant] Okay, killer.
And do you want that one?
- I may go a little bit
thank you economy on it too.
It's funny, I had a really
interesting text conversation
with AJ, had a six hour
flight this morning.
We were talking about Jamal Adams,
the Jets rookie phenom,
I love this kid, so much charisma.
And we were talking about intangibles.
I really, really, really
want to talk about the gray.
The intangibles.
Really the reason why I have
not been physically gifted,
but still have won a lot of games,
because it's the intangibles,
it's not the black and white.
About to go on stage here in Portland.
Real pleasure, man.
- [Fan] Right on.
- Congratulations for everything.
- Yeah, thank you.
- [Announcer] If you
guys all could just...
Let's welcome to the stage Mr. Gary V!
(applause)
(classical music)
- Fuckin' intangibles,
like the stuff you can't measure,
you can't measure this, right.
You can measure how strong, or how fast.
You can measure how IQ smart,
you can measure how many hours.
You can measure all the black and white.
It's the gray intangibles that
are really the fundamental difference.
As you push yourself to be a
better fuckin' human being,
Better things start happening
for you in your actual
selfish business wants and needs.
And it comes from kindness,
it comes from patience.
It comes from a million different places
but it's slight little intangibles.
I never have to rush to the
arena, and I'm like, weirdo.
Hey, anybody?
Are we done?
- [Girl] Yeah one more, one more.
- [Gary] Yes, let's do it.
- The truth is undefeated.
Truth wins.
- Yeah.
- And so, I've become
comfortable in that truth,
even at my own peril.
I speak about my shortcomings
a lot more than I used to,
because if you're gonna embrace it
you've gotta embrace it fully.
- I know.
- It's playing a different game
than everybody else is playing.
It is that thing that makes people win.
I'm about to do this
interview for these guys.
For what the blog or?
- Yeah, for-
- Social?
Just content.
- Yeah, content.
- Just about to do some fuckin' content,
Stayed on stage forever,
got a big fire back home
that I've got to address,
got a phone call, gotta
get to the airport.
(laughter)
Meet and greet.
Let's do Rhodo.
- So I have two questions.
- Go ahead.
- Cool.
The first one's about Snapchat.
- Okay.
- So, I run the Snapchat for a franchise.
- Yeah.
- It's based out of Arizona.
(girl whoos)
Hey!
(laughter)
- I'm just like, it's up so early.
They had to catch a flight.
- She's a gangster.
- I know.
- That's your girl?
- Yeah I'm dating her.
- Dude, you're dating her?
Like, she's really your girl.
Okay.
That's Not exactly where I was going
but it makes it awesome.
Go ahead.
- So what is it?
What can I be doing-
- To make it better?
- Not only to make it better,
'cause like, well, damn,
yeah, I guess, but like-
- Do you want people
to come into the store?
- What's up?
- You want people to come
into the business right?
- Hell yeah.
- Let me throw a really
interesting curve ball at you.
You should literally take
the account right now,
look at it, and be like,
"Hey guys what can I do here
to make it better for you?"
Like one of the craziest moves in social
that I find fascinating is
just asking the audience
what they want.
You will be blown away by
how much feedback you get,
that will unlock, right?
Literally, like,
"Hey it's Rhodo," you know?
"I run the fuckin' ship for this store."
Like, "What up?
"I need you guys to tell,"
and now you've got, Snapchat's
legit now, you can just keep
holding it down so you're fucking good.
You don't even have the 10-second
bullshit anymore, right?
So you're just holding it
down, and you're like, fuckin',
"It's Rhodo, what up, like,
fuckin' run shit here,
"like, what do you guys
want on this Snapchat?"
Here's what's gonna happen.
80% of them are gonna be like,
"Give us free shit."
No shit, dick.
Yeah, exactly.
(laughter)
Which you can mix in.
By the way, I'm on a whole
kick at Wine Library now,
every Saturday we're just
giving away $10 worth
of gourmet food.
I'm like doing it, and like,
the ROI actually works,
so like, giving away free shit,
people like to shit on it,
it's kind of clever if
you've got something good.
'Cause the cost of entry is low,
but look, you know this.
People want entertainment.
And you're fucking entertaining
just on your fucking face.
(laughter)
You know?
- Thanks, brother.
- I mean it.
I believe you.
Remember when I talked
about, "Bet on your strengths
"and not your weaknesses?
Go fucking all Bill and
Ted's Excellent Adventure.
You know?
Go all, I mean it!
(applause)
I can taste it from this far away.
You'd be entertaining as fuck,
and it would bring people.
Make every fucking person
want to watch it for you and
fuckin' Larry the fuckin'
mop guy,'cause he's funny.
Like, create a fucking sitcom, bro.
- Thank you.
So, before I get to my second question-
- Yup.
- Would you mind if I took
that Snapchat right now?
- Yeah.
Let's do it.
- [Rhodo] I appreciate that.
(applause)
- Yeah, Rhodo.
- Alright, here we go.
- Go ahead bro.
- [Rhodo] What's up D.T. West Side?
(cheering)
I'm here with Gary V.
He's a huge motivational speaker.
- He never heard of me before today.
(laughter)
- [Rhodo] We're here and
we are curious to see
what you guys want to see
and we're curious to hear
what you guys want to
see on this Snapchat.
- Tell him!
Tell him what you fuckin' want!
Can we do that?
That's okay, right?
It's good, it's approved.
Approved from the top.
(cheering)
Yeah!
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
(cheering)
- [Fan] Thank you so much.
- Yeah, of course.
- [Interviewer] Where was
the first time that you ever
realized that you could
just really speak honest,
and you were like, "Oh, this
feels right, this feels good?"
- I think the most honest
place I've ever been
was in competition.
- [Fan] Great to see you.
- Thank you, brother.
What's your name?
- My name's Jamison.
- Jamison.
- Yeah.
Pleasure man.
Thanks for the love.
- Thank you!
- [Gary] Take care guys.
Bye, take care.
Thank you brother.
- Have a good day.
- Thank you.
Take care.
You know, the place where
I'm most honest was always
where I was competing.
Tennis, gym class hockey
was a very competitive thing
in my high school.
Backyard basketball, ping pong.
When business, when I
started to be in business,
I got very competitive.
I look at it as a sport,
so I go on tilt.
When I get competitive,
I go like a bull, like it comes red.
I guess when I started
really being out there as a
personality in my mid-30s,
the camera brought a level of,
I know somebody's
watching this in 39 years,
and I'm fascinated by that.
I don't know.
I think I'm trying to
discover the answer for you
and the audience.
I don't know.
I can tell you that I continue
to build momentum on it.
I don't know when I
first started doing it,
like going really there,
but I definitely do it more than ever,
'cause it's right.
The truth is undefeated.
Truth wins.
So, I've become comfortable in that truth,
even at my own peril.
I speak about my shortcomings a lot.
More than I used to.
Because if you're gonna embrace it,
you gotta embrace it fully.
(dramatic violin music)
Cancer's cancer.
That's why I always try to
be the best at what I do.
'Cause I want nobody to
have leverage over me.